I just have to say that you're amazing I
came in and I felt very sort of like
I've been doing a lot of press and I was
sort of in like press mode and kind of
like saying the thing and then just you
sharing that thank you for sharing and I
felt like just an immediate connection
and like the Press walls kind of dropped
and then I was like just like a human
moment
so much
[Music]
I was voracious and went after you like
a crazy person wanting to have a
conversation with you because of the
things I went through in my life and
with my mom
and growing up in this industry
first of all this cover I love you so
much the humor
how did you get to the humor of this did
you earn it have you always had a sense
of humor well with the title
specifically I always knew that I wanted
it to be called I'm glad my mom died I
wanted something that would be really
bold and attention grabbing and
hopefully that people with a sense of
humor would get you know and also I
think anybody with who's experienced
parental abuse understands and I I
didn't feel so concerned with I knew
there would be you know some people who
are like I don't get that title but I
thought that'd be that'd be totally fine
and when people maybe don't get the the
comedy and the tone yeah how do they
behave and what how does it make you
feel
um I try to stay off like Twitter but
every interview that I've done so far
the the interviewer has been sure to let
me know hey that title is very divisive
um and I think that anything worth
saying is probably going to be divisive
I think if it's not divisive it's
probably there's probably no new
conversation to be had there so I felt
it was an important and worthwhile title
does someone have to die in order to be
able for us to tell our truth I think we
at least have to write as if they have
died which is that old saying right like
right as if everyone you know is dead
um I've never heard that one before I
don't know who said it but I'm pretty
sure it's it's like a I I think it's a
saying I don't think I just coined it I
know I've never heard it before I've
definitely heard like right as if no
one's reading it or dances if nobody's
watching I mean by the way that's the
new mug being sold dog shelves I'm
actually asking honestly yeah like
do I have to wait to tell on my truths I
don't know if I can do it because
certain people are alive I understand
my thought on that is I think if saying
the truth ends a relationship I think
it's probably a relationship that needed
to end I guess does that make sense like
yeah it does it probably there was
probably some painful uncomfortable
truth that was just needing to be
expressed for a long time and if saying
that
out loud is going to end the
relationship I think it's probably
better off not being in a person's life
how do you get over guilt and shame if
they're still alive in order to tell
those truths
oh my God
guilt and shame are tough I really I I
struggle to navigate guilt and shame for
a long time I would get them confused
but I was told by a therapist that I
loved that guilt can sometimes be
worthwhile because it can say oh maybe
there's a correction to be made in like
a life path or a lifestyle choice but
that shame is not really worthwhile that
it kind of keeps you stuck and can like
Spiral that was really helpful
to understand I think the nuances
between the two so I would say the shame
the shame is is is I just don't think
it's a a valuable
emotion really but I do think with guilt
do you think it's warranted guilt do you
think it's unwarranted I think when it
comes to our moms
we want so badly to have this
relationship that I can't even say
society says we're supposed to have it
is nature it is nurture it's Evolution
when you met your therapist
is it true that you were like my mom's
great things are good everything's
awesome I just have to say that you're
amazing I came in and I felt very sort
of like I've been doing a lot of press
and I was sort of in like press mode and
kind of like saying the thing and then
just you sharing that thank you for
sharing and I felt like just an
immediate connection and like the Press
walls kind of dropped and then I was
like just like a human moment
much here to ask advice I I relate to
your journey so much I feel like I have
a lot to learn from you oh man I really
do I'm so glad you said that because I
don't think of this as the same thing I
I wanted I just was like can I please
talk with her I one human being to
another yes that feeling is just yeah
wow and also I knew I could trust you
because you did have comedy in there
when it's all so dark and heavy I'm like
I don't want anything to do with you if
you haven't found comedy as a coping
mechanism we have nothing to talk about
So when you say that I feel like I can't
take somebody seriously if they're too
serious because I'm like they don't
where's the humor like there are Shades
to reality it's never just dramatic it's
never just funny it's always layered and
messy and gunky and that's juicy you
know I couldn't agree more because as
actors you're like put it all out there
you think you're so out there but like
that dark stuff that's in there right
it's real deep and buried yes so how did
you start your therapy journey and how
did you start to unpack well initially
when I when I went to therapy I did have
my mom still on the pedestal and every
time I felt defensive immediately when
my first therapist Laura started asking
questions about my mom immediately I
went into well she did this but it's
because she's such a good mom it's
because she wanted me to be successful
it's because she wanted me to have a
better like everything had a I I was so
defensive I didn't realize that I was at
the time but in retrospect I see oh I
was disclaiming every single thing that
my mom did instead of just stating the
reality or how I felt about it it was I
was more concerned with how I how to
keep my mom looking good than I was with
expressing my true emotional reality
okay I think I'm having an aha moment
Tell Me Maybe it's protectiveness that I
feel
[Music]
I've never put it in those terms in my
head wow I got bills
it's like I don't want to paint her
negatively I don't want people to think
of her negatively yes but the truth is
tough stuff
[Applause]
yeah I
it took me a long time to accept that my
mom
was not perfect let alone abusive like
it went in baby steps to to put these
pieces of the puzzle together and to
recognize the reality of the pain that
I'd suppressed for decades at that point
you know I first went to there when I
was 20 22 or 23. wow what did your
therapist do that made you feel like you
could keep going because I think it's
interesting because at many different
therapy approaches many different styles
people who are out there maybe wanting
to open up to therapy what's a red flag
what's a green flag what was it for you
interestingly I'm only now piecing this
together but so I left my first I talked
about this aspect in the book but I left
my first therapist when she suggested I
was telling her kind of stories of my
relationship with my mom she said hey
what you're expressing is is abuse
are you aware of that I broke down I
quit therapy that night and it takes you
want to run away oh yeah maybe it was
too harsh too fast yes like I started
with eating disorder with an eating
disorder specialist so it was very
clinical very checklist pen and paper
and we didn't get into trauma or
childhood stuff we didn't get into any
of that and I think I needed that at the
time because I I think I needed to get
that addiction uh under control before
being able to go anywhere near like
Excavating the stuff from the past I
think that was to it would have been too
I think that would have fueled the
addiction if I were working on that in
tandem with the addiction so you had
positive experiences breaking down one
of the aspects of what you needed to
work on and your eating disorder has a
history oh yeah I mean your mom talked
about calorie control when you were
young 11 yeah
it I mean
the way your mom spoke to you
it it obviously is so unacceptable that
we find as adults now who know better
but how do you know what's okay and not
okay when you're a kid
um
I
I feel like the thing is when like
when you're a kid you don't know that
you're in a traumatic situation or that
you're in a not normal situation because
it's just your reality you have nothing
to really compare it to it's just so
your own
your own experience so I had no idea
that I was in a
traumatic environment to me that's where
some of the comedy actually comes from
is because it's like that denial
innocent child point of view so my mom
would be chasing my dad around the house
of the kitchen knife and I'd be like
rooting her on I'd be like oh mom like
you got this and it's like that's messed
up but when I was six I didn't know that
was messed up my dad used to come in and
break he used to come in our house and
break everything and my mom and I would
come home to like the entire house like
just ransacked and it you know I was
like well I could I know this weirdly
I was so rational with my dad
I don't know how he got a free pass I
was like you're an incapable person you
are totally screwed up talk to me about
what happened with your dad
so after I guess this was maybe a year
and a half after my mom died my who I
thought was my father told me that he
was not actually my biological father
what was your first reaction
um
I remember feeling like I got the wind
knocked out of me my mouth was really
dry
uh and I
I think I hugged him and then um his
then girlfriend sort of like joined the
hug and she was well-meaning but I was
like
okay this is just a hug between us too
we don't need another Embrace on top of
it yeah I feel like that always happens
when there are two people hugging and
there's like a third person standing in
the room who feels left out they're like
I guess I should join and I start
joining we're like oh this is excessive
God I think sometimes I have been that
third person hugging
probably more often than not I'm like
really that's a license to hug all right
let's bring it in It's probably hard to
know how to react did you did you say
okay this person's not my biological
father but he's been there as a father I
didn't feel that way I felt that he had
always been pretty disengaged and
disconnected so
um it was shocking
but I I also started to find excuses for
him in that information
meaning oh well that's why he was so
absent all those years not really
realizing well that that wasn't oh also
you know what he said to me he said
it's not your fault you were born
he repeat and then he repeated it he
like doubled down and then tripled down
and I thought like this is the weirdest
thing to say to somebody after you've
just told them that you're not their
biological father what did he mean by
that I I don't know he I don't know I
really have you ever asked him no I just
didn't I sort of just that was that was
a relationship that I kind of
let dissolve let disintegrate it wasn't
there wasn't really much there to begin
with and so you were like here is my
green light to not have shame or guilt
and move on initially I felt a lot of
guilt and tried to really work on that
relationship and and and you know see
him and and his then I guess maybe she
became his wife shortly after that
um I tried to see them quite often and
then it just didn't feel right in my
bones I just felt like this is that I
what we're talking about there's no real
connection here it just doesn't feel
um it just doesn't feel right in my
bones and and so then I just so time
allowed you to start to disengage yes
yes what about your biological father
I I went to meet him and
um we had a really great kind of first
conversation and then we saw each other
for maybe three to four months once a
week probably for that amount of time
and then it got to a place where that
one felt a little
a little strange also my brothers two I
have three older brothers two of them
are all Brothers follow your biological
Brothers yeah and they hadn't met him
and I was sort of doing the thing of
like trying to get them to meet him and
thinking like oh this could be good this
could be healing for all of us and we're
gonna build that family uh exactly oh my
God that was my goal
from oh my God being a little girl was I
want a good family I want a good family
I I really understand that wanting to
create the nuclear family like you you
will make it work you know you you and I
found my friends you know now I have two
kids and a huge family and when their
dad and I didn't work out that was I
that took me down like that was it I was
like this was the almighty plan I didn't
know if I would even ever have children
because of my relationship with my mom
and then when I did and it didn't work
out it I I I didn't think I could
experience more trauma failure wow and
emotions than when that happened I was
like oh this is the big one I thought
that happened when you were 13 or blah
blah blah okay we can always be
surprised that the nervous breakdown's
gonna happen it
40 and not 13 in a mental institution
what a revelation okay
[Laughter]
I but I I we are we're now doing great
you can make it till you make it good
but those kids first were like a model
of co-parenting I really mean it like
I'm so glad we got there we're survivors
you get there you make it but do you
ever do you want children do you think
about having children do you have a
vision of what that is are you like what
what is your feelings about
that I don't think I want children I'm
open to my mind changing on it like it
so far hasn't seemed appealing to me
um but I wonder why
[Laughter]
oh my God I know
as soon as I found out I was having a
girl I was like oh
here we go let's get on that karmic
wheel and fix this and then I found out
I was having a second daughter and
everything changed really I was like oh
um ah you're gonna raise girls that's
your purpose here on this planet wow and
it changed everything oh my God yeah oh
that's so nice to hear oh my God it was
a real relief I I know this I know I
don't want to have kids from
um like to to get an identity you know I
feel like I'm lucky there because I've
done a lot of work on my identity and
myself and feel clear
um as clear as possible I think at 4 30
and I know that will continue to evolve
and change and I expect that
um but I also wouldn't want to have kids
out of any sort of boredom or to save a
relationship those are kind of the three
things where I feel like oh if I don't
do those I think I'm off to a good start
you are so healthy
I mean really you are just so healthy
this journey of self-awareness
methodologies opinions insights into
life
are so profound and they're paying off
so much I have to say I think you'll be
an amazing parent if you choose to be
one thank you I really do you think just
have your head on so straight and you're
so clear on everything and I think
us who didn't have a certain type of
love maybe even have more of it to give
as a last question if I may who are you
now oh that's a that's a giant last
question that's huge that's really big
who am I now you know I feel it the
simplest answer I guess is that I feel
like myself I feel like I lived so long
being sort of who I thought I needed to
be for different situations and um and I
feel like I never could have sat down
here and just talked to you as me
like it's so powerful to be able to to
feel like I can be authentic and feel
like I can be me and my skin and not
have to run from that and pretend to be
somebody that I just don't that I know
deep inside is not me like that's
I I do think kind of so many people
relate to that specific Journey whether
or not they're in the entertainment
industry or acting or what have you I
think that that journey of authenticity
that's the corniest way of phrasing it
that it can possibly be afraid oh it's
true it's a like even if you tell your
truth you'll be okay yeah yeah I think
just
I think just yeah being being authentic
there's such a a nice feeling to it
that's like can't be taken away or
um compromised and that feels really it
feels like legitimate strength not like
over compensatory strength ooh big word
I get a point
I love big words
I am
so happy to meet you you too it's so
helpful and healing thank you so much
for everything that you're putting out
there and I just uh
I love you
I'm glad my mom died is available now
everybody knows about it because it's a
best seller and it's being downloaded
and breaking records and
that's what the truth can do
thank you Jeanette thank you so much for
having me this has been like so amazing
oh my God
[Music]